welcome to the show we're trying
something a little bit different today
I'm going to be joined today for the
hour by Dave Rubin host of the political
talk show the Rubin report on YouTube
our sort of daily political wrap-up and
stories will be on today's bonus show so
extra incentive to sign up for that
bonus show so Dave it's been I think it
may be about a year or more since we
last had you on and why when I announced
we were going to be having you on
we received close to 500 different
questions and and concerns and maybe
about 50 insults which is about the
right ratio that I find for you and
we're going to dig into a bunch of this
stuff but to sort of set this up I got a
tweet from someone the other day
unrelated to this interview who said I
like a diverse media diet
I watched the David Pakman show on the
left and I watched the Reuben report on
the right which was sort of surprising
to me it what's your assessment now of
where your politics are do you consider
yourself to be on the right so to speak
yeah well you've given me a lot there to
start so I'll do the best I can here
back man yeah first off the 500
questions to only 50 haters or insults
that that's an extremely for the
Internet in 2017 that's a phenomenally
good ratio so I want to be clear about
that first as far as that now I'll dress
it in a broad sense first and then I'll
get to your exact question in the broad
sense the person that commented on that
that's a beautiful thing and that's
exactly what we need more of regardless
of left-right or anything else or what
you think about my politics or your
politics we need more people that are
willing to listen to people from across
the spectrum and in in ways that you
wouldn't have listened to people years
ago meaning do it through podcasts or
YouTube or however else you do it now
and all those things what we need more
than ever in this country I believe is a
multitude of voices who are trying to
get across ideas so that we can have the
battle of ideas so we can figure out
what the best way to move forward as to
the specific question of okay I listen
to pac-man I left proven on right I mean
I have said consistently we relaunched
this show you
I was at the Young Turks for a while as
you were an affiliate with them as well
at the time we relaunched the show where
it became an interview show basically
two years ago is September 9th 2015 so
I'm sure about a month and that's when I
had Sam Harrison on that first episode
and we did a one-on-one interview and
the second I was done with that
interview I thought wow this is what I
want to do you know before that I was
doing sort of a news panel thing and I'd
have three guests usually comedians a
little more like hot topics on the view
or something but I did that show with
Sam and I thought wow we did into
something important and relevant and
real and honest and I and I loved
interviewing people and I had done it
before a little bit I had a show on
Sirius XM and some other stuff but
that's really where I shifted that's
where I started talking about these
ideas of liberalism and the phrase
classical liberalism which I'm proud to
say is now out there in the in the ether
yeah and you hear this being spoken
about more I mean nobody was talking
about that and I still have all sorts of
problems with people usually on the
right by the way who still associate
everything else a Liberals this Liberals
this when they really mean they either
mean progressives or they mean people of
the left which sort of gets to the heart
of your question so first off I don't
think the left the right thing really
has much bearing anymore I've said this
many times but I think the Trump elect
you know the election and then the Trump
presidency has tossed the chessboard up
I had Andrew Clavin on here a couple
weeks ago he said it rammed the truck
through everything whatever metaphor you
want to use for it it has created a
situation where everybody is really a
ting whatever it is that they believe
and why they believe it so when you just
say the typical ideas of the left or of
the right to me it's really more about
libertarian versus authoritarian I don't
mean libertarian in the political party
I mean a sense of individual liberty
versus sort of state authority
technically look technically if we were
to get all the definitions in the
old-school way of looking at them a
classical liberalism which is pretty
close to lib to libertarianism
practically is thought of as on the
right side of the spectrum so I don't
again I think these things are kind of
archaic ways of talking about things but
you know we all get caught in labels I
say it all the time you know I have to
use labels at some level to get ideas
across and then at the same time as
labels change they become less useful
which by the way it's one of the reasons
that I don't say regressive left as much
as I used to because I think we made a
point with it and people started
understanding what we were talking about
because for a long time people were sort
of thinking a lot of the things that
that you and I have discussed they were
thinking these things they needed a
label to sort of grasp what we were
talking about now I think people
understand it so I've shipped it away
now some people use it more that so be
it but anyway if you want to get down to
the technical side of it I would say
that that true liberalism classical
liberalism which is about the individual
and live-and-let-live and and logic and
reason I would say that that's firmly
truly in the center because what you're
really trying to do is is bring in the
fringes because you realize that most of
us are in somewhere in the center yeah I
mean I see but I think that also there's
a lot there I mean to sort of get to
whether your politics have changed
because that's one of the big questions
is so aside from where however you label
your place on the spectrum there are
many who believe your politics have
decidedly changed when you used to be
arguably sort of under the progressive
umbrella but you differed with some of
your colleagues on issues of free speech
and censorship and the
israeli-palestinian conflict - really
now under the label of classical
liberalism supporting more genuinely
right-wing ideas before we dig into any
specific policy do you believe that your
views have actually changed or are you
labeling your views in a different way
no my views have been change I've said
this a couple of times if anything I
would say on some economic stuff I've
shifted a little bit more libertarian so
I'm taxes for example or on some
regulation stuff which I'm happy to
discuss if you want but in terms of
everything else in terms of gay marriage
I'm married to a dude he's in the other
room
that's pretty for gay marriage I'm for
legalizing marijuana I'm for euthanasia
for reforming the prison system I'm
pro-choice I'm basically for
single-payer health care these are all
things that are thought of as either
or last or liberal or whatever so yeah
I've shifted a little bit on some of the
economic stuff because by the way for
the last two years I've sat across some
brilliant thinkers and public
intellectuals and professors mostly
people that have argued in front of the
Supreme Court I mean experts in their
field who have shifted some of my views
a little bit right in terms of economics
well in terms of everything else I
believe those same things by the way I
will say this that when I was on The
Young Turks I always considered myself
liberal I don't think you'll ever find a
moment where I flat out said I was a
progressive I was around a lot of
progressives and at the time I thought a
lot of what they said made sense but
then as I sort of had my awakening you
know one of the things that I think a
lot of your audience will be familiar
with this and maybe you are to a degree
as well is that when you start seeing
the corrosive effect of a lot of this
stuff that's happening on the Left right
now it starts under it undermines almost
all of the rest of it at once but and
once you see it you can't stop it's like
a wave and then you go wait a minute
this one little thing I think a little
differently on this and and suddenly you
see why it affects so many other issues
yes I mean let's pot let's pause on that
part because I do want to dig in more
into detail on that in a subsequent part
of the interview but to get to the
politics of it the policies you describe
a lot of them they they're sort of at
odds with classical liberalism I mean
want to give you one example and I'm
wondering maybe if the classical
liberalism term is being used a little
too loosely right now by some and we're
doing a long form deep dive into
classical liberalism that we'll be out
in a couple of weeks I mean one example
would be a sort of foundational
classical liberalism tenet is the
government should be involved not at all
in anything that the free market can
provide now it's not can provide
efficiently or can provide pretty well
but can provide so according to
classical liberalism health care is
something that should be 100 percent in
the free market and that means no
pre-existing conditions or it costs ten
times as much if you have pre-existing
conditions
Asians or whatever it is that for-profit
corporations want to do the view you
stated yourself having on single-payer
health care it could not be more opposed
to classical liberalism so is it
possible it's maybe not the right label
for you no it's not possible it's not
the right label because I know all the
types of classical liberalism quite well
and I and I assure you it's not look
I've had many people on I would
recommend your your audience check out
some of my interviews with Steve Davies
with Randy Barnett with Deidre McCloskey
these are these are professors at what
very well-known schools who've explained
a lot of this stuff brandon davies from
cleansing a bunch of other people sorry
Brandon Turner basically I think for
this look we can we can whittle down
every definition to every this is
exactly how you have to think if you're
this or that I mean we could we could
sit here and go well you know you're
only a Democrat if you exactly believe
this or exactly believe that nobody
Democrat I think that's it to be clear
Democrat is a political party
affiliation and I think that's very
different than an ideology like
classical liberalism which has some
pretty well-defined characteristics sure
so for most of the guests that I've had
on here who identifies as classical
liberals I would venture to say almost
everybody actually the easiest way I can
explain it is that if you are a pure
libertarian and and this is hard to pin
down because libertarians are sort of
all over the place you have the wing of
libertarians that don't want driver's
licenses and then you have libertarians
think are a little more realistic and
then and then by the way you have an
Capps who want absolutely no government
and all that stuff classical liberals
generally I think believe that the
principles of the individual and of
liberty and your right to do things for
yourself and free-market principles by
the way are the best way to go about
doing things but there's a realism there
related to the state which is that it
exists it has to provide certain things
especially in a country like America
where we have 300 or 350 million people
whatever it is and that there has to be
some balance so I've seen many times and
this would be the the view that I look
at a classical liberal position
generally it sort of it sort of takes
the libertarian
principal and then add some element of
realistic government involvement so you
know we can whittle down to those words
being absolute necessity or whatever it
is but I think the general accepted term
is that there's some government
involvement but you want to always err
on the side of individual freedom which
I absolutely do on the issue of the
single-payer health care though because
I think this is a good lens specifically
because of your views on this do you
agree that single-payer would not be the
libertarian perspective with a slight
tweak to make it the classically liberal
perspective it is diametrically opposed
to what a classical liberal would want
yeah you know it's funny I I get invited
to a lot of college things and I'm
always invited by the way--by
by conservatives or libertarians usually
or people of the right which is funny to
me because you'd think it shows that
they're certainly willing to talk to
people who are pro-choice and Pro
and I get no invites from anyone left so
I was doing a speech for the students
for Liberty in DC a couple maybe two
months ago and I'm talking about all
these things that I'm for and I said
something about the Hinkel single-payer
health care and they booed me but then
everyone started laughing after because
it was very obvious that the whole
purpose of me brink coming there was
that we don't have to agree on
everything and then we all had a good
laugh about it I thought what a great
moment that is that we can all go you
know what we still want to live in the
same country anyway as far as
single-payer health care this isn't I
haven't done a tremendous amount on
health care on the show and I should do
more actually why is that
or maybe we'll save that for later
because I noticed that that you don't
talk about that and it's potentially
affecting you know tens of millions of
people tomorrow you know what I mean I
was surprised that you weren't talking
as much about it
um I think it's sort of about ancillary
bounced in and out of the specific you
know I what I try to do on the show is I
like talking about the principles and
the ideas mostly and I try not to get
caught in the sort of day to day the
news part of it and especially because
of the way people consume news now it's
like everything changes so quickly in
the 24-hour news cycle changes so
quickly that I don't want to always be
doing the catch up on that but but what
that's fine I would say that to me the
best idea for healthcare as I see it
would be that basically you would have
the the private companies would be in
control because they have to decide what
they have to make money they have to
have a functioning business I do believe
that's a realistic thing at the same
time there is a piece of do you want
people to be able to get health
insurance that have pre-existing
conditions absolutely do you want to do
things that aren't always about the
bottom line that this is where a
libertarian might say okay well it's
tough for that person and they have to
go to their local church or their
whatever their community and help them
now I believe the state does have some
responsibilities there I think this is a
classical liberal position so so I would
say the best the most realistic way that
I think you could do this basically
would be that you would have private
companies that would sort of all be
facilitated and exchanged with some
facilitating by the government it isn't
that Obamacare like isn't that Obamacare
basically said we're still keeping
health insurance as a for-profit
endeavor but in order to participate you
have to abide by certain restrictions
and we will also sort of regulate some
portion of these plans through an
exchange like I'm hearing exactly what
the Affordable Care Act is yeah well
first off you can go back to my tweets
and many videos that I did I was not
against Obamacare yeah no and I don't
read as a criticism and it's just
sounding like what the Affordable Care
Act well I wasn't I wasn't against
Obamacare I was frustrated with a lot of
how they did it you know I'm not someone
that believes that the ends justify the
means and if you remember when Obama was
running he was constantly talking about
how transparent we're going to be and
we're going to air this stuff on c-span
and everyone although and we know whose
all backdoor deals and congressmen that
were suddenly retiring out of nowhere
after they sign things and all kinds of
shady stuff but that's just government
nonsense which is another reason why for
small government as a general rule I
think that there is some overreach by
the government on I have a some issue
with the government forcing people to
buy something there's something there
but I could I can basically get over
that look I can tell you this I have a
very good friend who
for the last ten ten or fifteen years
has been a very successful doctor I
don't want to say what state he's in but
a very successful doctor Obamacare came
in and his practice in many ways has
been wrecked because he stuck with all
these regulations at doing more
paperwork than seeing people and all
this other stuff now I know that's just
an antic total thing but you do hear a
lot of these stories so the basic
premise though of what you're saying
having some exchange that the government
says you have to sort of hit these
certain marks I just don't know that
it's exactly been rolled out properly I
think there's a lot of evidence that it
hasn't but again I mean look at the day
Obamacare was passed I tweeted something
that got something like 50 was 50
thousand retweets which at the time I
think was one of the top 10 most
retweeted things ever so but so Dave I'm
trying to I just want to just so we can
drill down so you're you're agreeing
that what you described as your ideal
scenario sounds like Obamacare but your
problem with Obamacare isn't how it was
written but rather that the
implementation wasn't exactly as it was
designed um well no there are first of
all for stuff I'm not a health care
expert I mean I know everyone wants to
pretend they're experts and everything I
don't it seems to me that there are
probably unnecessary regulations or
expectations out of some of the
insurance companies and and the doctors
frankly I'm working I'm less concerned
about a giant corporation that's an
insurance company that we know companies
make tons and tons of money I'm much
more concerned about the ability for the
doctor and the patient to have the best
relationship possible the doctor to make
the right choices which I've heard a lot
of things from from several doctors that
there are reasons sometimes that they
can't even make the best choices that
they think to do or sometimes they'll do
a procedure before they think it's
necessary all sorts of other stuff but
the basic premise of what Obamacare is
of the government facilitating the
private exchanges I don't have a don't
have a problem with it but like most
things private or public but especially
public it could probably be done a
little better fair enough yeah and as
far as you know I think that one of the
big issues is if we had single-payer and
we had also outcome based compensation
rather than you get paid for each thing
that you do which is sort of one of the
key aspects of the system we have you
would eliminate a lot of what we're
seeing doctors doing but let's put a
pause on the healthcare conversation and
in fact we'll take a quick break and
then Dave we will resume with you and we
just have so much else to talk about
we're speaking with Dave Rubin host of
the Rubin report and we'll be back after
this we're continuing our conversation
with Dave Rubin who is of course host of
the political talk showed the Rubin
report on YouTube growing by the day I
think is fair to say so Dave let let's
now turn to we've sort of talked a
little bit about your political views
generally and I want to get a little bit
to some of the most popular questions as
I mentioned nearly 500 questions and
about 50 insults that came in related to
this interview some of the insults
directed at you some of the insults
directed at me lots of anti-semitism to
go around no shortage of that ever but
there are a couple things that kept
coming up okay one is and I know you've
heard about this the criticism of your
interviewing style and as it as it
generally goes the criticism is there
are people who go on the Rubin report
they say things that are demonstrably
untrue or at or at minimum highly
deceptive and Dave Rubin doesn't
challenge them so let me just sort of
give you the opportunity to explain what
your approach is and why what underlies
what some might perceive as not
challenging guests when when maybe they
deserve to be challenged yeah well first
can you give me an example of that
sure so like for example when you had
David Horowitz on and he said Obama is a
communist and he did include it in a
sentence where he said a lot of things
that were untrue you could have I guess
conceivably picked out any of those
things but it was just sort of allowed
to slide where if if you had a different
style you might have said can you tell
me what Obama has done that makes him a
communist in his legislation or whatever
the case may be I guess that's one
example okay so I don't so first off
David Horowitz saying that Obama's
economist that's his opinion of what he
thinks about Obama before I don't know
that you can say
I've actually debunk abel though right
you could say well if someone is a
communist there must be something you
can attribute to them that would be
communist 'ok uh well i think I don't
I'm not David Horowitz is lawyer or
arbiter here but I think he would argue
that the policies that Obama put in
place like Obamacare whether you agree
or not for other thing or large taxes
and things like that that he would do
those as as communist ideals let's say
but are we putting that aside yeah um my
my interview style by the way you know
it's funny to take questions I don't
take question as an interviewer I don't
take questions from my audience because
I always feel that it's it's better
these things come from my head and also
there's an odd self selection so if you
tweet out you know I'm taking questions
for Dave or whatever you know mostly
what you're going to get is the haters
because those are the people that know I
know they play I mean you know me well
enough to know that I mean the questions
that I did not even pay attention to or
the ones that I really think we wouldn't
get anything out of like as an
individual I believe I'm curious because
your style is so much different from
mine your style might be better I mean
there's no rule that your my style is
better I'm curious what your approaches
in terms of style yeah I don't believe
me I'm not I'm not accusing you of
anything I just think there's an
interesting we always forget about this
self selection which is important
because in a day in a day of social
media you only hear from the screaming
people of than I even see this I even
see this when I get emails you know I
get tons of email every day people
saying really nice things I get people
you know I get Muslims in Saudi Arabia
and Christian conservatives in Missouri
saying to almost the same exact things
to me and then you know but the ones
that stick out of my head are the ones
where people just tell me to go you know
eff myself or badly okay put that aside
my interview style I said this many
times is I believe that the best way to
interview somebody is to really be able
to hear what they think and the way you
do that is you listen now when David
Horowitz in this specific instance when
he said that communist thing I was in
that particular case I was about to stop
him but you're right he then did quickly
he like sort of said it it was right at
the top of the interview he kind of
right into something else and then and
then the conversation just went from
there I do remember thinking the
interview that I wanted to get back to
it but in the course of an hour
conversation I think that one was almost
an hour and 20 minutes you know
sometimes something's going to get lost
my belief is that if you let people
speak you can either figure out if they
know what they're talking about or not I
think one of the problems that we have
right now in mainstream media and you
know 10 guests in little boxes screaming
at each other and all this one of the
things that it's done is that it's made
it so that everyone talks in sound bites
I've done some of these cable news shows
I think you have even when I do those if
you know you only have five minutes you
gotta say things real quick and also if
you want to get booked again so I sort
of say in a passion way and Bubba and
over-the-top and all this stuff this is
terrible for for public discourse it's
terrible for the extrapolation of ideas
and it's terrible for for a real
dialogue that we should be having so my
belief is that if I sit across from
somebody and I really listen to them and
and listen to them say what they think
then I try to ask the right question to
figure out why they think that but my
goal is not unless I'm having something
that's closer to a debate which you know
two or three weeks ago I had Michael
Shermer who's skeptic and dennis prager
who's a believer in morality and god it
was it's what I believed it to be more
of a conversation than a debate because
I think that's just a more helpful way
to view it but my view is let these
people talk and you can tell you can
tell because I don't think my audience
is stupid I think my audience is really
bright as I suspect yours is as well
when someone doesn't know what they're
talking about or when they believe
really lie they will hang themselves you
will you can see it they will wrap the
rope around their neck and they will
hang themselves so I try to ask the
right questions to get the most out of
them yeah I mean I think this may be
it's just a difference in approach right
but like I would imagine maybe you're
right that David Horowitz thinks Obama's
a communist because of Obamacare and
taxes but then I would say it might this
is my instinct you know I would say well
what taxes are you talking about and
then it would be like oh he's a
because he allowed the top income tax
rate to go from 36 to 39 percent I mean
it's like it so my interest would be in
if there's an assertion made that is a
what I've you know I didn't know the
president was a communist that's
interesting how do you define that I
feel like we would get a lot out of that
you know and it's not it's just a
difference in approach I think as what
we talked it up - sure
and that's listen I always say to people
people will say well I don't like the
way you do this early that I'm like well
someone forcing you to watch this thing
if you've got someone that you like
better than me watch that or if you
think somebody's a better interviewer
that best I diffic this is just what I'm
doing I like it people happen to like
what I'm doing which is great but yes
you know by the way in that interview I
was really I thought we were going to
spend almost you know he David Horowitz
was a hardcore lefty child of Communists
who was a lefty Berkeley guy in the 60s
who then evolved and now he sort of is
hard right I think he's probably he's
probably he's heard he's pretty hard
right maybe not diamond but whatever is
the next softest stone yeah he's right
no doubt about it
but my purpose of that interview he's
written many books of you know I had
recently done that video only a few
months before on Praeger about why I
left the left and why I don't think
liberalism has anything to do with the
left and print and Horowitz had sort of
been through that experience many many
years before has written many books
about it wrote an article about it
during Reagan's re-election so I really
wanted to focus on that so occasional
look occasionally something's going to
get by it's just how it is and by the
way you know my my friend and and who
I'm thrilled to call a friend and honors
a girlfriend and mentor Larry King you
know a lot of people used to say that
when Larry you know he's still doing
interviews now and I love him and I just
saw him last week yeah but you when he
when he was in his heyday let's say in
the 80s and 90s on on CNN a lot of
people said well he doesn't attack the
people the right way he doesn't follow
up the right way blah blah blah I I
think my follow-ups are actually pretty
good and I think as I said bye-bye
subtlety talking to people you can get
them to explain themselves sometimes
into a corner if they don't know what
they're talking about but you know
everyone's going to have their critics
and I'm actually completely okay with
that and by the way maybe in five years
from now I'll look back and go oh I
should have done that a little different
or you know I you know every one of
jobs and figures things out I think this
the quick rush to judgment I think is
kind unfortunate but it's alright hey
I've got no shortage of interviews I
look back at and say what on earth was I
thinking that day but unfortunately I
can't redo those a lot of those people
don't talk to me anymore sadly I'm kind
of kidding but know that the certain
certainly looking back and wishing I had
done things differently I think is a
common thing
we're talking with Dave Rubin host of
the political talk show the Rubin report
on YouTube more after the break
let's pick up our conversation with Dave
Rubin host of the political talk show
the Rubin report on YouTube so I thought
it would be interesting Dave to talk a
little bit about because you're
increasingly not doing this on your show
deliberately as you talked about in
order to stay away from the sort of
24-hour news cycle generally speaking
were six month in month into the Trump
administration how do you assess this
presidency so far you know I think it's
unfortunately it's become so polarizing
even talking about Trump that making an
assessment that's a clear honest
assessment no matter how you do it
you're gonna you're going to get some
hysterical stuff but I'll do the best I
can
yeah so first off just to be clear I did
not vote for Trump I voted for Gary
Johnson and I should be judged
accordingly I did videos on how to stop
from I talked to people that I admire at
the highest level such as Sam Harris on
why you shouldn't vote for Trump and
what his fears were from the week before
the election I had Hillary Rosen on who
is a progressive pundit and those tons
of work with the DNC about why she hated
Trump then I had plenty of Trump not
plenty of Trump people I had a couple
Trump people on including Scott Adams
who I think was the best public advocate
for if you wanted to vote for Trump why
to vote anyway I did not vote for him my
feeling was after after the election my
feeling was that the the fact that the
chessboard as I described before has
been thrown up and everyone's revaluated
things versus that if Hillary had been
elected the screws that'd about all the
stuff that we talked about about
mainstream media and the corrupt
politicians and all this stuff those
screws would have been tightened it
would have been really bad for
independent media
people it would have been bad for just
the slow degradation of society that
we're seeing and discourse what all the
screws would have been tightened against
us so Trump although I did not support
him by throwing this chess board up or
driving the truck through it or whatever
you want to use to describe it I think
that has created a net good in that
right now there are more people talking
about politics reevaluating what they
think getting engaged whether for him or
against him then I've certainly seen in
my lifetime
okay so let's pause there briefly
because you just now you just said a lot
I think you're about to get to the parts
where we're going to disagree but so far
you've said something I've been saying
for a while which is if Hillary Clinton
had won we would have seen significantly
lower engagement in politics you would
have seen many on the Left sort of say
hey we've got a Democrat in the White
House so we can sort of tune out for
four years which would have led to a
disaster in the 2018 midterms and the
reality is that as someone who was a
center to center right in Hillary
Clinton which I believed her to be I
think it actually would have not been
particularly good for the left which I
consider myself to be a part on so so
far I agree with you the Trump
presidency and the what I see as the
endless scandals have really
reinvigorated activism in an interesting
way not exactly what you said but I'm
sort of agreeing with you here yeah and
and I think that that's all legit and
also you know that fits within the
things that I care about the things that
I care about are talking about the ideas
talking about the principles again not
necessarily every day-to-day decision or
monitoring his Twitter so that I can
start getting outraged because now
there's you know there's media companies
that literally spend all day waiting for
him to tweet so they can write about how
outraged everyone is so they're doing
pre outrage before people even have a
chance for irony now as far as the
actual presidency I guess we should
spend a minute on on Russia first just
because that's what everybody seems to
go to now look it seems to me that they
haven't been able to pin anything
directly you know a month ago it was all
the Comey stuff that didn't seem to work
out two weeks ago is all the Trump jr.
stuff that didn't seem to work out this
week I guess there's some anaphoric
stuff we'll see if that works out if if
we were to go on the assumption for a
second I'll do a bow
ways for you if we're going on the
assumption that Trump did somehow crude
with Russia then what you're saying is
that technically we should be at war
with Russia right now that you'd have to
then depose Trump and of course pence
and then I guess you then install the
Speaker of the House Paul Ryan now in a
lot of ways by doing that you'd have a
worse person for the Democrats because
Paul Ryan by most estimations especially
economically is certainly to the right
of Trump and maybe on some social stuff
yeah but Dave let me I don't want to I
want to interrupt you but only because
we've done the Russia stuff up and down
I'm more curious like for example on the
stuff Trump has actually done like not
whether he colluded with Russia but what
is there like a particular policy or
something Trump has done that you think
is really good and or what has he done
that you think is is really a disaster
if there's anything like what do you see
is the highs and lows of the six months
yeah just give me 30 seconds on the
Russia thing I can wrap that up though
because my point is that if you're
saying that there was collusion or they
knew about us we are in effect at war I
mean could there possibly be a bigger
act of war than installing a president
so what you're saying is that it would
then be President Ryan where we'd have
to lead you an election and get Hillary
I mean the first thing we would have to
do is go to war with Russia I do not
want to go to war with Russia I don't
think there's any reason to go to war
with Russia but hypothetically did would
you say going to war with Russia is so
bad that we should allow an illegitimate
president if it were determined to be
such no okay okay did it good yeah no I
book I believe in evidence on logic and
reason so if one day if tomorrow
literally the second I hang up with you
right now if I go on Twitter and they
say well we figured it out we actually
got the kill
it's figured out Trump was installed or
the Russian government actually colluded
and then we had to go ahead and do that
well then of course I don't want a
Russian puppet but all I'm saying is you
need evidence yeah and I think we have a
lot more Ferrier than evidence okay so
that's one thing
well adds to your other question the
specifics of the policy look when george
w bush was president i was against the
executive actions when when Obama was
president I was against executive action
when Trump who's now used a ton of them
I've been against them we have three
branches of government we can do a
little Polly
1:01 the legislative branch is supposed
to write the laws the executive branch
signs them into law that the president
and then the of course the Supreme Court
of the court systems figure out if these
laws are legal the idea that we're doing
so much through the executive branch I
think is horrific for for democracy and
for the rural law and for how this
country is supposed to operate so the
fact that he is so willing to do that
and by the way it shows you the
limitations of this silliness so when
Obama did all this stuff with electronic
pen or whatever he did well guess what
it all because it didn't go through the
legislative process it all got reversed
by Trump with the sign of that same pen
so I think the the deferment of power
which by the way is there's everyone's
culpable in this we the people are but
Congress which doesn't pass laws anymore
and doesn't have real debates and really
figure out what they're trying to do
there they're very good at investigating
themselves and investigating other
branches of government but they don't
seem to be able to pass laws and
function the way that they're supposed
to and be the representatives of the
people that they're supposed to be so
that my main issue with him is that
obviously the Trump is a wild card and
that I don't know what the Trump
political ethos is other than it's for
Trump I get yeah there's this make
America great again or you know drain
the swamp or all those things but that
to me is not a political ethos I care
about ideas I care I want someone to
come in and say these are the these are
the principles that I believe in and
this is how I'm going to try to govern
and I simply don't know what that is I
don't know what Trump's moral Center is
if there was a real crisis you know if
there was a horrible terrorist attack or
if there was a Missile Crisis with North
Korea sighing he's trumped the the
level-headed person you want dealing
with this now you could probably on his
people we make an argument that he's put
in people like mattis that that would do
these things well and and he would defer
to them okay that's that's possible but
my biggest issue with him is that I just
don't know what his political beliefs
truly are other than sort of a day to
day machinations of playing the media
and playing that fight and I don't think
that that's great for democracy but has
he not done anything like his tax policy
proposal or
what it is that he seemingly wants
although who really knows it seems like
he doesn't even now it seems he that he
confused health insurance with life
insurance this entire time but what he
claims to want to do about health
insurance or whatever is there any
policy idea that he's put forth that you
say that's what I disagree with the most
it's a disaster
well the tax stuff I don't particularly
disagree with I this is as I we started
the interview I said I've shifted a
little right on taxes I believe you have
the right to keep as much as you earn as
much as you can as you are now I do
believe we need to pay into the system
to have roads and social services and
things like that which by the way there
are some libertarians who don't so I
think this is something that you could
couch in that classical liberal Avenue
but but lowering taxes as a general rule
I'm completely for even if it was in a
way even if it's in a way that would be
bad for the economy um well I well you'd
have to you know I guess what I mean
yeah that's sort of vague I mean what I
mean is there we have nothing we can
point to that suggests sort of
supply-side stimulus by tax cuts for the
very rich is good for the economy we
have periods where it's been done and it
hasn't been acutely bad but there's no
period there's there's no evidence that
it's good so for me I would say okay
there's the question of what's ethical
or moral and there's also the question
of the economic impact of it that's sort
of my background so I would say it's
hard for me to support something that
would be economically damaging well I
don't know that there's any direct
evidence that it's economically damaging
but also we would have to widdle through
and we could do this in a week or so if
you want we'd have to widdle through
exactly what the tax plan said but again
as a general rule I want you David
Pakman as a small business owner which
you are with employees to pay the least
amount of taxes that you can so that you
can hire more people so that you can
build a better studio so that you can
invest more in your operation and bring
the goodness that is you and your
operation out there I know this as a
small businessman now if I had been
being taxed higher right now I admit
capital costs to build this studio and
do all this stuff by the way I pay a
hundred percent of my employees health
insurance a hundred percent I also give
my director gets a gets a cut of our
YouTube bread I do all the things I try
to put my beliefs into practice but
that's a confusion for me Dave because
if those capital expenses are tax
deductible so if the tax rate goes up
for you as an individual if you've got
pass-through income or for for the
business tax rate it doesn't matter what
the business tax rate is is if you want
to spend money on capital because that
you don't pay taxes on that actually it
encourages you to spend money on capital
to have a higher tax rate so I under I
understand what that argument is and I
would argue at the same time as that
yeah that having every one of us every
one of us whether you whether you
whatever however much you earn it is
your money it is your money we get taxed
in all kinds of other ways with sales
tax and everything else I pay payroll
tax and blah blah blah and I would say
the best way to if you right now if
you're on the left or you're a
progressive and you hate Trump and you
hate what this government has become I
don't think that the best answer is to
topple the government and destroy this
incredible experiment which is what it
is this American experiment I don't
think the best way is to destroy I think
the best way is to rein in the power
that it has over us and one of the ways
you can do that is by giving it less
money I think that the government could
function a lot slimmer and trimmer I
think most people I think actually you
could probably get most progressives to
admit that the government is a giant
waste but often they'll tell you how
much they hate the government and then
the solution is more or more taxes I
would say the only way to really control
this stuff is to is to tighten the
strings on the finances and you have the
right to or keep as much as possible of
what you are fair enough and that's more
more of an ethical argument than an
economic one I think you would agree I
would have to look at the eye
I suppose in this case I'm making the
ethical argument which I think if things
were more done on the grounds of ethics
yeah then sort of staring at numbers and
projecting things and the CBO which
projects things for twenty years and
it's always wrong about everything or
all the pundits who project things are
always wrong
all the polls that are always wrong I
think doing some things based on ethical
principles might actually have some more
long-term positive benefits to society
all right let's pause there we'll be
back for our few remaining moments with
Dave Rubin host of the political show
the Rubin report on YouTube back after
this sticking with us is Dave Rubin host
of the political talk show the Rubin
report on YouTube we've talked Trump
we've talked classical liberalism we've
talked about so many different things
okay so Dave I sat through what felt
like a very enjoyable endless hours of
Rubin report and there's a couple very
specific things I want to touch on
because I feel like they might be
attacks on me personally not not
directly but de-facto you said in an MMU
you said innocent in an interview with
ben shapiro that liberalism is basically
a mental disorder what did you mean by
that
I don't think I said liberalism I might
have said progressivism or maybe you
said the left is basically a mental
disorder that I think the idea was
progressivism the left left ISM whatever
the case may be it's basically a mental
disorder for the record if I said
liberalism then it was an absolute brain
freeze but I'm 99% sure I didn't say
that it managed in before if they have
been before you started what before you
shifted language on it it was a little
bit a little bit ago yeah I don't think
so though but anyway I'm sure that some
of the Internet's loops around here will
find it I'm pretty sure I said
progressive okay um well first off if
you had nothing to do with you you know
no I know it to be personally but I am
curious like what about progressive
ideology strikes you as being a mental
disorder okay so first off I said it in
a glib way to I think it's an actual
mental disorder no I don't think it's a
mental disorder that should be studied
and I would like to study a couple of
these progressives but I would study
some conservatives do and one you know
you could probably figure out that their
brains are wired a little differently
okay fine so putting that aside the big
I was being glib obviously but the point
that I'm trying to make is that the I
sort of what I just said you in the
previous segment if you
our issues are the gut think about all
the proof I mean while I was on TYT for
years everything's about the
government's horrible everyone's corrupt
everyone's evil corporations money is
destroying everything billionaires
bah-bah-bah what's your answer make the
government bigger tax people more force
the government to do more below that
seems antithetical to logic and reason
so I so yes it is not a mental disorder
but I think basically if you could get a
group of progressives to sit down and
not scream at you that you're a bigot
and a racist and a homophobe which by
the way I'm sure that there are people
that flirt use those slurs on you even
though you are of the left and consider
yourself a progressive I think if you
could get some people to sit down and
really talk about ideas and these
principles and this philosophic
underpinnings of the things that we're
talking about I think you could get
people to understand that if your
problem is the corruption your the
problem is the money and all those
things then stop making the problem
bigger that this isn't about what the
founding fathers intended they intended
a very weak federal government and local
control and local power and state power
and I'm for all of those things so yes
the comment was done glibly but I assure
you it had nothing to do with the attack
well I think that this is where you know
we sort of get to what I think is my my
core disagreement with you aside from
like really specific policy things like
it seems like we're sort of in a
different place on tax policy for
example probably don't agree exactly on
what the size of the government should
be but you and I have talked privately
about our concerns with the sort of a
speech policing trigger warning safe
space stuff we both talked about that
we've expressed concern about some
knee-jerk positions that don't seem fact
based on the israeli-palestinian
conflict etc I think it's a matter of
degree that I think you believe that
those issues are much bigger among the
left than I perceive them to be
and I've talked about the college campus
stuff that's going on but I still think
it's limited to a particular type of
mostly you know liberal arts colleges I
don't think it's the major issues
some of your guests make it out to be
are we sort of having a disagreement too
on the degree to which these issues are
a problem yeah so I would say that the
fair place to have a disagreement which
finally I love having a disagreement
pacman you know I like you I consider
you a friend do you we're going to do my
show if you were going to be in LA last
week it didn't work but we'll get my in
here the whole point of this experiment
as I described it before of America is
that we're supposed to disagree on these
things we're supposed to disagree and be
able to walk away and realize that we
want to live in the same society because
I don't want to kill you for your
beliefs and hopefully you don't want to
kill me for mine so as for the the free
speech stuff no I I don't think that I'm
overstating it or that my guests are
overstating it this this idea of the
trigger warnings of the safe spaces of
the speech police of deep platforming
Richard Dawkins at Berkeley which is
happening on August 7th he's been deep
platform I'm after I'm actually
interviewing him in New York at the 92nd
Street Y on August 8th they haven't
stopped us yet but I'm sure there will
be people that aren't happy that we're
doing that this kind of insanity
stopping Jordan Peterson from speaking
being I'm sure I don't have to tell you
about what happened with brett weinstein
up at Evergreen State so everything's a
great example by the way because this is
supposed to be the most left that you
could argue that this is the most left
college in America or certainly in the
top ten so you would think that they
would have all this harmony that these
ideas of non racism and plurality and
all of this stuff in multiculturalism
would have worked but the students there
would have you believe that this is some
sort of insane racist crazy place Bret
Weinstein was fighting racism he was
fighting segregation now I get that I
defended him I mean I got a call about
it a couple weeks ago and I defended him
and you know a lot of my family is is
college professors and I've got an
announcement to make about a college
involvement that I'm going to be having
and from my from from everything I'm
looking at there are these several dozen
examples that you cite but the idea that
the left at large has been taken over by
this it's like I went to the women's
March rallies here in Boston and there
was about 10% stuff that I thought was
totally unproductive and a shutdown of
attempts for open debate and it was bad
and I'm against it but I'm just not on
board that it's a
them to the degree that you think it is
and I think it's really easy to look at
these isolated incidents and believe
that it represents everybody on the left
but I'm just not seeing it well first
off I've never said it represents
everybody unless it represents what the
mainstream West has become without
question now we can just didn't agree on
the percentage there and that sign but
these look we know that by they've done
a zillion Studies on it I don't want to
quote the number wrong but that's
something like 80 or 90 percent of
professors in America are liberal to
left now it depends what you mean by
liberal of course in that case but we
know that the conservative viewpoint is
not being taught in in colleges and by
the way it's leaking into not just the
humanities it's actually leaking into
the science stuff and I was at a
conference with about 400 college
professors in Dallas a couple weeks ago
and many people were talking about that
so I've talked to tons of professors
about this I would recommend if you get
Jonathan Haidt on your show I think he's
doing the best work on this and run
something called a heterodox Academy
which is about getting more diversity of
thought at college campuses but when I
go to college campuses I get kids from
every walk of life and every color and
sexuality and all that stuff all that
diversity that the left loves I care
about diversity and thought more but I
get kids saying that they their teachers
are telling them to use certain gender
pronouns they say well I'm not against
trans people but if I see someone they
happen to look like a man I'm going to
say he or him and I'm not trying to
offend anybody and if I may want them to
use Z or Zed or whatever the hell it is
that these ideas these ideas which are
taking root in the left this strange
alliance with Islam all of this stuff
that taking root left is not being
countered by anyone on the left actually
any time someone on the Left tries to
counter it they're kicked out and and I
think you can probably speak to that
yourself and certain listen I mean I get
criticized no there's no doubt I I mean
I'm on the left and I counter it I've
not yet been kicked out of any place
none of my college speaking events that
are planned for the fall have been
canceled so far I mean if it happens
I'll absolutely tell you as well as my
audience you know yeah well I don't know
what your specific criticisms have been
that they would that what they would
lead you to lead them to kicking you
well yeah but as a general rule as a
general rule there is no question in my
mind that that people that are thought
of as traditionally right at the moment
are being more tolerant of other ideas
than people of the left it's just I I
see this in every walk of life I also
fear that the the biggest problem we
have right now is that the ideas of the
left of a bigger state of taking more of
the collected versus the individual I
would recommend your audience watch my
either of my interviews with ayaan Hirsi
Ali who does a wonderful explanation of
the individual and why we have to care
about individual rights as opposed to
collective right yeah um I these ideas
of the left I think are a far bigger
because they've taken such root with
young people I think there are far
bigger threat to the future of this
pluralistic wonderful society that we
have than anything that I see coming out
of the right at the moment you could
actually make a lot two arguments that
the right has changed there's virtually
no one on the right that cares about gay
marriage anymore that's a pretty that's
a pretty significant levodopa that right
to media if you should see them the
people that write to me no listen I mean
I think that I think that that's um was
that what we we've now gotten to the
maybe biggest disagreement that we have
which is I really believe that that the
opposite of what you just said is true
which is that these are relatively sort
of compartmentalised problems on the
left and unfortunately we've reached the
end of our time I think the audience
will not be shocked to hear that we
disagree on that but exactly okay yeah
give me 30 seconds here who on the left
beside you is calling this stuff out who
is calling out this crazed
intersectional lunacy of the Dyke March
and who's calling out Linda Sarsour and
all that you know what they're not
they're actually tweeting more and more
I stand with her Bernie and Van Jones
and all of these people so who is doing
it in an effective way calling out their
worst elements I don't know I don't know
any of those people I'm like I'm in my
silo here in Boston but but think about
that
and that's why I'm saying they're being
led by their worst elements because they
because people are afraid to step up
because
they'll be called racist and bigoted and
all that others so that's the part that
it that's why I believe that it is so
corrosive and it is silencing people in
a really dangerous way Dave Rubin host
of the political talk show the Rubin
report I don't know whether we've solved
any problems during this conversation
but it's been fascinating and I think
that just having it is something that
hopefully my audience will enjoy Dave
thanks for taking close to an hour of
your time to talk to me today
my pleasure pac-man let's do it again